i'm at the wired party at ces 2012 and
it's time to talk about trends
so tablets were a big trend developing
at the show this year
we have seven inch tablets 7.7 inch
tablets
honeycomb tablets ice cream sandwich
tablets these are all versions of
android we have tablets that are about
to become ice cream sandwich
we have tablets running nvidia tegra 3
quad core processors so everyone's
coming out
with a different kind of tablet that's
meant to compete directly with
the apple ipad of course but also the
kindle fire and the prices are getting
much lower so
tablets were sort of disappointing last
year but
ces is giving it another big shot for
2012.
so that's tablets also very interesting
fitness gear
and so everyone's coming out with some
kind of device that could help you track
how many
stairs you're climbing how many miles
you're walking there's even a device
that we checked out last night you
attach it to your left forearm it can
tell you how many calories you've burned
and it could even you could leave it on
overnight so really cool stuff coming
out in the fitness space
there's tvs the big oled
lg tv awesome great picture quality
of course 3d tvs are back as well can't
wait to get out there for one more day
check out more and finish up a great ces
2012.